Mauricio is joining the meeting anyone
there hi it's me who's here who's there
before we get going I want to make sure
that everyone can see the slide hey can
you see the slide I can see there's a
little box on my screen that says Anita
flash black in oh do tell very quickly
we are you doing a Mac or a PC don't
worry you'll be able to keep up just the
most important thing for the next
meeting is that you oh it's a meeting
over its next meeting okay great thanks
guys this is great hey you know this
very important to us we discussed this
thing it Christine that was tragic but I
want you to think back to the last time
you had virtual meeting I bet two things
that one one of those things happened to
you and I also bet that it wasn't that
long ago your last virtual meeting took
place because according to an article in
The New York Times between 2005 and 2012
the prevalence of virtual meetings
increased 79% why are people using
virtual meetings so much more that
part's actually pretty simple one it's
cheaper Cisco for instance has 200
telepresence rooms and it estimates that
that phase would come to be a hundred
million dollars a year chuckles so
that's pretty compelling second they let
people who need to be there actually
access anything instead of dealing with
the fuss of traffic and snowstorms which
if you're like me from Chicago is a big
deal then you can just tell a commute
and it also lets people who are junior
sitting on calls they might not
otherwise get to be part of something
that I really appreciated when I was an
analyst third
you could like this 70% of people would
rather telecommute ku meeting than
physically can you so why is that well
forbes asked that question why do people
like virtual meeting so much and this is
where the dark side of virtual meetings
comes out because 64% respondents that
64% of you in this room said you like
virtual meetings because it lets you
multitask that means that you are
admittedly checking email surfing the
web and reading content that is
completely unrelated to the meeting
you're supposed to be in furthermore
Forbes said well take this list of key
attributes that define business success
and tell us what percent of you
I think virtual meetings are conducive
to those the results are pretty dismal
so here's your situation right
nobody likes meetings to begin with
virtual meetings are becoming more
prevalent and virtual meetings are
uneffective so what do you do what do
you do well I think you have two options
one you can be part of that sixty four
percent that checks out or like the good
GS beers you are you can see this as an
opening are you going to be part of that
group that sits back or are you going to
have influence are you going to clear
your inbox are you going to get
promotion if you're part of the first
group feel free to pull out your phone
now but see you later
once your name on a building but if
you're part of the second group listen
up because today we're gonna tell you
how to have success in a virtual meeting
how to be the virtual meeting hero
through the proper preparation execution
and handling of the aftermath there's
specific to virtual meetings so that
while your peers are being dismissive
and getting overlooked you are getting
noticed
to be prepared is half the people so we
want to share with you and strategy to
be prepared a M T empty as ac/dc song so
first agenda define what success is who
is the team required to to achieve the
success and invite them be very mindful
compared to a regular meeting about time
constraints and please share the gender
other pants okay and with the rules of
this meeting second materials we have a
greater efficiency challenge here about
time compared to regular meetings so
please make the materials assign roles
assembly works and set them on advance
also choose the format you know
telephone be the conference and also try
to set the login and password on time
finally technology assure that everybody
shares the same platform don't be like
me last week I assume I have a video
conference in Skype and in the last
minute I just realized that Google
hangout existed and we lost like 10
minutes because my fall off download in
the app so be sure everybody shows the
same format be sure that all tech works
and please don't have a talk pocket dog
you know select a proper professional
place and arrive at least 15 minutes
earlier to have a great meeting in this
way with this a empty strategy you will
be great prepare for this Metro PD so as
Stanford students of course you're gonna
be leading these meetings you're not
gonna be sitting back and just observing
passively so what do you do what do you
do as a leader of these meetings well
the first thing you can do is start on
time just please start on time
see virtual meetings make it so easy to
come up with excuses for people to not
start on time and it's it's a problem in
the workplace and the real meetings it's
even worse in virtual meetings the
second thing you can do is write down
the names of participants see in virtual
meetings I can't see your faces you
won't be able to see mine
so how do you understand how do you know
who's in the room who's not who stepped
out to go to the bathroom how do you
keep tabs on who's participating and
who's not third tip I can give you is
limit continuous talk to me have you
ever been in a meeting and you kind of
raise your hand
Shaylee or make some some type of
connection with the speaker to try and
speak and then he realizes and gives you
the chance to speak well newsflash this
is not working virtual meetings if you
want to actually talk and you want to
actually give people time to speak you
need to limit your talk time to give
people a chance to participate and
finally have round table check points
see some people thrive on structure
others people like the mess and the
noise it's really hard in virtual
meetings when there's when there's no
structure and people are speaking to
interrupt so have those checkpoints give
people a chance to speak but what about
that off chance when you're not the
meeting leader asks ask them for lumps
that might actually happen to you too so
the first thing to do is for a lot of
God did not multitask the both dates
asking these engages your mind from one
task and re-engages in another you don't
really you're not really paying
attention to two things at the same time
you're just switching back and forth and
that makes it really hard the second
thing you can do is lead with your name
we're going to speak see what have you
been preparing this huge speech this
huge thing you're gonna say it's gonna
get you your promotion and then suddenly
no one knows who said it you say it and
then next meeting someone takes credit
for your work so start with your name
say my name is this is Joaquin this is
what I'm gonna say
third interrupting is difficult
sometimes you just need to write down
where you're saying what you're thinking
and go back to it later so don't don't
make that mistake
not writing down leaves you will forget
you will forget after the meeting and so
write it down have a chance to speak
with the person and take off those
topics and finally paraphrase
paraphrasing can help you get influenced
in the meeting even if you're not the
meeting leader why does you can cut
through the noise you can say just what
I'm hearing this is what's happening and
that immediately shines a spotlight on
you so you've gone through all the items
on your agenda you've got a list of
action items for the next meeting your
virtual meeting is done right no it is
not there's one more thing you have to
do to make this virtual meeting a
success formalize the water-cooler
conversation what do I mean by that well
another key difference between a virtual
meeting and an in-person meeting is the
fact that after an in-person meeting
concludes people will typically leave
the office where the meetings being held
and they'll gather go gather informally
in different parts of the building
sometimes it's the water cooler the
office kitchen now anyone who's been in
an office knows that this is where the
real information is shared it's not
about the office memo it's not about the
email it's not even about the formal
meeting you just sat in for an hour
it's the chitchat that happens in
between so you have to keep this element
alive in your virtual meetings if you're
going to maintain the integrity of your
team if the people in your project if
you're a leader and you're leaving a
group on a project they all need to feel
like they are part of that chitchat so
you need to formalize the water-cooler
conversation to be a true virtual
meeting hero it's a lot easier than it
sounds you're just gonna ask people at
the end of the meeting say hey everyone
I'd really like to get your feedback
about how this went specifically I want
to hear your concerns
I want to hear things that you disagreed
with and I want to know what we can do
differently next time to make
this an even better meeting give them
the chance to say it they're right there
in the space you may not have any takers
that's not unusual that's what happens
in a real-life meeting but make sure
that you follow up as the team leader
it's your job to reach out to people who
are joining you remotely to follow up
with them to make sure that they don't
have any issues that they weren't
feeling left out because if they were
you got to fix it and do it right the
next time so we have given you guys a
lot of information and you have given us
a lot of information there's a lot of
information here today being shared and
it's all great we've taken the liberty
or rather we will be taking the liberty
of putting together a tip sheet tip
sheets already put together with the
liberty is uploading it to to canvas so
that you can have these these tips at
your fingertips in advance of your next
virtual meeting because as we mentioned
earlier if you're not part of the
solution you're part of the problem and
we would urge you to take action be the
hero of your virtual meeting